salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor on
est toujours à Berlin regardez-moi ça on
est sous un pont caché déguisé en
travailleur un nouveau spot on va tenter
ça on va voir ce que ça donne il y a
deux points en plus on est toujours avec
Wim
et Timothy qui a déjà jeté les mains pré
comme jamais
quand même
ok ça se lève
j'ai déjà senti ce truc il se lever et
lâcher
il est superbe magnifique
[Musique]
le fameux couteau arme demeure
réveil bravo
regardez ce que je viens de trouver un
original Zippo on n'a pas encore tenté
mais il faut savoir qu'il nous arrive
assez fréquemment de repêcher des hypo
et que ceci sont censés être garantis à
vie donc on pourrait les renvoyer on va
essayer tenter l'expérience avec
celui-là
elle est bonne
citron et un mot c'est une photo
de la personne
[Rires]
[Musique]
heureusement
regardez ce qui vient de trouver
il se toys
elle est cassée
petite pince
alors là je viens de trouver ce cadenas
qui a été fracturé
donc c'est bon signe encore une fois
c'est récent ça montre qu'il y a des
objets récents et que ça ça a peut-être
déjà été fait mais
que ça soit rempli et là j'ai ça on
aurait dit un chargeur mais non je crois
pas
c'est juste du métal ok on continue
regardez ce que j'ai trouvé les enfants
England
pro
action England donc c'est des menottes
anglaises
au téléphone
England
[Rires]
[Musique]
la petite cabane qui fait plaisir et
regardez quand même cet endroit
en plein vers là
les amis
c'est vraiment super beau
voilà le look a pris 4 heures de road
trip et 6h de pêche à l'aimant on est
comme ça voilà on est encore déguisé en
travaillant
on ressemble à rien dans Berlin en plus
ils sont tous très bien habillés et nous
on a de la boue sur le visage c'est
totalement improbable
on aura bien mérité une petite pause
on a changé de côté du pont
et j'ai un vélo
on va attendre un peu qu'il se vide
il est encore parfait
les pneus sont gonflés
quand elle va souvent faire un tour avec
et ouais c'est déjà pêché ici c'est
dommage
parce que c'est un très bon spot c'est
pas souvent le cas en vidéo mais
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment crevé et
c'est dur de continuer c'est la fatigue
après tout sera trip
il continue mais doucement doucement
parce que
c'est pas du travail
nickel
et hollandais pareil il fatigue un peu
comment on reconnaît un pêcheur les mots
français en Allemagne
il se fait le maquillage
dernier côté du pont
on est prêt il y a un peu plus de pièces
de ce côté donc soit c'est moins fait
soit il jette plus soit
ça veut rien dire mais c'est quand même
un bon signe donc on va voir ce qu'on
arrive à sortir
plus de pièces aussi garde-les
pour le parking
elles sont en bon état cette fois-ci
et ça c'est quoi comme pièce
alors là
je pense que vous dira ça après mais
et encore plein de pièces plein de 2
centimes
et 5 cm
j'avais fait un debout comme ça là je
sais pas ce que c'est ah ouais bien joué
avec un badge
OK
[Musique]
à part la pluie franchement ça va mais
voilà le temps c'est vraiment terrible
et je pense qu'il y a quelques pêcheurs
aussi et regarder j'ai vu la pièce de 2
€ et j'avais même pas vu ça
et il y a une pile aussi donc ça c'est
une bonne dépollution on met tout ça de
côté
vous allez vous rendre compte
pour le coup non bah non
c'est encore de la fonte
mais là je vais encore avoir plein de
pièces à mon petit
on va regarder
Doro a je crois que c'est la marque de
téléphone pour les personnes âgées
mais voilà tu as gagné j'ai gagné
en plus j'ai des pièces quand même un
beau 5 centime tout neuf
un pauvre il est dans la voiture ah oui
d'ailleurs pas rester dans cette vidéo
il est en train de dormir
ce matin il était il était avec nous la
première vidéo si vous l'avez pas vu à
Berlin parce que ça vaut le détour elle
est totalement dingue et oui donc
rastador bon il est dans la voiture il y
a pas de risque là il pleut et il est en
train de se faire sa meilleure sieste je
pense qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
belle surprise
encore une pile c'est un peu inquiétant
et quand même des pièces aussi
ok une pièce qui sauve l'honneur mais à
part ça c'est pas glorieux
voilà donc c'est la fin de cette pêche à
l'aimant à Berlin si ce pont donc c'est
pas de pas d'armes encore rien
incroyable on va continuer demain à la
mise sur Google on continue à Berlin nos
amis seront de retour en Hollande dès
demain et là c'est pour empêcher avec
nous on va prendre la route un grand
merci en tout cas d'être venu merci et
allez voir la chaîne YouTube
à bientôt on espère que vous avez
apprécié cette vidéo pour nous le
retraits en Allemagne continue n'hésitez
pas à nous suivre sur insta pour plus de
photos exclusives du voyage regardez le
seul bâtiment de Berlin qui n'est pas
tout propre ils ont laissé les plantes
c'est original
je fais du repérage de spots
je pense que c'est